it's almost time to go yo but before we
do I have one more story to share this
is what I'm liking
last month an author in Ohio took to
Twitter to vent about a recent book
signing with a disappointing turnout she
wrote only two people came to my author
signing yesterday so I was pretty bummed
about it especially as 37 people
responded going to the event kind of
upset honestly and a little embarrassed
that author was Chelsea Banning and she
was promoting her self-published debut
novel of crowns and legends I think any
artist can relate to that kind of
disappointment at a show but what
happened next is truly amazing it's very
cool the post went viral and authors
like Stephen King Margaret Atwood and
Neil Gaiman chimed in with their book
signing horror stories as well the best
part of crowns and legends rocketed up
the amazon charts not too shabby we have
Chelsea joining us now what's up Chelsea
hi Kelly how are you I am so good I love
how this story like it turned out
because how bad was the signing oh it
was
heartening because I was there a few
hours and only a couple people showed up
and I was still feeling sad on the way
home and the next morning and I just
really wanted to talk to other writers
about it so I went to Twitter to kind of
just vent into the void not really
thinking anyone's gonna see it and then
a couple hours later it went viral and
there's all these amazing authors uh
chiming in with their own signing horror
stories like you said Neil Gaiman
Stephen King Margaret Atwood and so many
more and even other celebrities and it
was just so heartwarming and encouraging
and truly a blessing well it is
important to note that everyone thinks
it happens like overnight like even with
me like I did things before you know
American Idol and you there are
disappointing turnouts and you think oh
my God like should I keep doing this and
it can be very discouraging so it's
important to tell people these stories
and it's also important for people like
the Stephen King's market hours to join
in and say this happened to me as well
it's it's a very cool thing and
congratulations on writing a book in the
first place and sharing your voice with
the world that's an incredible thing to
write a novel so tell us what it's about
uh so it is a King Arthur reimagining it
takes place 20 years after King Arthur's
death and it follows the twin children
he and Guinevere were never supposed to
have so they weren't supposed to exist
and it follows their Adventures there's
magic you'll meet new characters you'll
see old characters from Arthurian myth
like Guinevere Merlin and all of them
it's book one of three and it's a
Trilogy that's cool as you said it it
it's soared to the Amazon charts and
Arthurian fantasy and now I even have
another signing at the same bookstore
later this month oh that's awesome I
love these kind of stories so I can't
wait to read it I'm so proud of you I'm
liking your post right now right
oh thank you so much and and that's not
all girl our season-long partner pilot
pin makers of G2 the go-to pin of the
Kelly Clarkson show want to honor
Fearless creators just like you so
they're going to be writing you a check
for a thousand dollars how does that
sound
I cannot wait to read your books
congratulations girl
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]